chad was pretty like you know he's
pretty athletic man he like the copper
where he's like
you know he's very limber and very like
his martial artist is definitely there
he's been training that
uh for for a long time so he's got he's
got that under his belt
michael b jordan is struggling to come
to terms with the loss of his friend
and black panther co-star chadwick
boseman
chadwick died at the age of 43 last week
after a private battle with colon cancer
now e.t has learned that the 33 year old
actor is struggling
and beyond sad he's at a loss for words
and was rocked by the news chadwick was
more than a friend he was a brother to
michael
and now he's trying to figure out the
best way to honor his dear
friend's legacy we're told that
michael's silence
is his pain the creed star has yet to
release a public statement about
chadwick's death
you have become them you will destroy
the world wakanda included the world
took everything away from me
everything i ever loved michael starred
opposite the late actor in the 2018
marvel action film as eric killmonger
the cousin of chadwick's t'challa
he had to buy into playing a villain
which is something he hasn't done
you know i had to buy into playing uh
to having the weight of of the hero
and sometimes the villain has fun you
know what i'm saying so
it's it's something that we both had to
buy into doing together and to
collaborate together and while michael
has yet to speak
out several members of the black panther
family have paid tribute to chadwick on
social media
were you there on set the first time
that chadwick put on that suit
i walked through you know walk through
the you know the
with the young men making it and coming
up with it and just it would
give you pause you just stand in front
of it oh
you know it was tremendous angela
bassett who played his mom in the marvel
movie
wrote that chadwick's dedication was
awe-inspiring his smile contagious
his talent unreal as a young man like
i love me some christopher reeves
superman was the man but like
my kid gets a chance to see t'challa he
gets a chance to see the black panther
and i'm really happy to be a part of
that story sterling k brown tweeted that
he had
no words and thanked him for being a
friend
has it soaked in what your character
means and what black panther means to
all these people
uh some of it has and some of it's still
like
watching over me like i still have
moments where i get
chills from it so it's an amazing thing
to think about
um to put myself in the shoes of a
of a kid now seeing it and and and happy
that they can take it for granted
actually
there will come a time when they can
take it for granted so it's a beautiful
thing